physical inactivity is associated with a
higher risk for severe covenanting
outcomes a study in 48 440 adult
patients
and most most of the conclusion is
discernible
from that from that title but i will
read to you just a couple of paragraphs
from the introduction as well
the u.s centers for disease control and
prevention the cdc
has identified risk factors for severe
cove at 19 including advanced age
sex male and the presence of underlying
comorbidities such as diabetes obesity
and cardiovascular disease
however there are no data regarding the
effect of regular physical activity on
covet 19 outcomes even though a lack of
physical activity is a well-documented
underlying risk factor for multiple
chronic diseases
including those associated with severe
copen19
they then go on to say that the u.s
physical activity guidelines suggest
that all
american adults engage in 150 minutes of
uh activity every week and that include
just a brisk walk actually counts
towards this so
what is that two and a half hours of um
you know merely brisk walking
or or more a week of physical activity
counts as sort of meeting the guidelines
next paragraph during the pandemic
populations across the globe have been
advised to stay home and avoid contact
with individuals outside of one's
household
lockdowns and other measures that
constrain travel have restricted access
to gyms parks and other venues where
people can be active
in the usa education about the benefits
of physical activity
and advice to maintain or increase
physical activity during the pandemic
has been essentially absent
while pre-pandemic levels of physical
activity were generally insufficient
pandemic control measures have likely
had the unintended consequence of
reducing physical activity even more
indeed early studies indicated a
significant reduction of physical
activity levels since the beginning of
the pandemic
so that's that's the setup and indeed
they refer
to another paper that was published just
last year which does indeed find that
while
and this is all it's self reports indeed
this paper itself is self reports of
physical activity as well but it's it's
a way of self reporting that has been
otherwise demonstrated to be um pretty
accurate
um we know that
the people reporting on their levels of
physical activity
in the wake of lockdowns many people are
saying it's the same
but to the extent that people are saying
it's it's different
many more people are saying i don't do
as much as i did before than are saying
i'm doing more than i was before though
there are some people in that
in that other state too so if this is
all true
[Music]
and if physical activity has an effect
on covet 19 outcomes
then we've got at the very least yet
another strong messaging problem
and indeed uh what this paper finds
is um let's see i'm not sure
yeah there is no the graphics here
aren't terrific so i'll just go to
one more paragraph in the discussion the
magnitude of risk for all outcomes
associated with being consistently
inactive
exceeded the odds of smoking and
virtually all the chronic diseases
studied in this analysis
indicating physical activity may play a
crucial role as a risk factor for severe
copa 19 outcomes
so you know again uh like we've talked
about before with regard to obesity
um there are some there are some things
that aren't even hidden but that are
hidden from conversation that are hidden
within in the media that are not
discussed
that you actually have control over and
even more than obesity because
you know some people once they have
become obese especially if that's due to
developmental
uh intrusions into their lives over
which they no longer have any control
because now they're adults
many people who are obese are actually
going to have a very hard time getting
unobese and that's not to say that you
don't have agency but it's tough
but do you have an ability to get active
does everyone in fact have an ability
to simply walk briskly for two and a
half hours a week i i say
yes and are there rare exceptions and if
you don't for sure
it's an emergency that you develop that
capacity that you build up to it exactly
so i just wanted to add here i don't
think this paper
discusses masks it discusses activity
but i want to point out the absurdity
in light of this of two things one
you know as we pointed out over the last
couple of weeks
the idea that one has to wear a mask
outside which is completely unscientific
manufacturing anti-scientific conclusion
but that conclusion portrays the world
as a hundred percent dangerous where it
is in fact
99 safe by virtue of the fact that it's
99 outdoors and the thing doesn't seem
to spread outdoors at least it hasn't
learned that trick yet
but the the fact of that missed
portrayal
in conjunction with the idea that even
outside
because it's all dangerous you must wear
a mask that idea which reigned until
a couple of weeks ago that means that to
the extent
that there was a question about should
you go outside
and be active there were really two
things marshalling against it one was
outside is dangerous so yeah you should
probably go out and be active but
you know it's you're not escaping covid
out there even though you really are
um but the second thing is that it
complicates being highly active
right as bad as it is walking around
with a mask walk running around with a
mask
or biking around with a mask or any of
those things is awful
and so it makes it less likely that
people will choose to do it it's harder
to do
uh and and in many places it was
actually forbidden for a while to
just go outside at all i mean i think
indeed one of the one of the studies we
talked about earlier which had this very
strange result about dog walking being
associated with
um with higher rates of covet and i
think that was in spain
uh after we talked about it we heard
from a number of people
actually this was uh if memory serves in
a city where a lot of people are living
in high-rise apartments and the one
thing you're allowed to do is walk your
dog
and in order to get your dog down to
walk them you have to be in these
elevators which are these tight
you know enclosed spaces and so probably
this was you know the dog walkers were
just simply the only people
who were going up and down the elevators
with an irregularity and that was likely
to be the
the issue but anyway there are a lot of
people who just weren't even allowed to
go outside
right weren't allowed to go outside but
imagine for a second
that the actual adults had been looking
at the actual evidence and making actual
recommendations for how you
actually avoid kovid and they had
concluded you know what
physical exercise is key obesity
is a disaster masks
are potentially helpful but not outdoors
and they impede
the very behaviors that are most likely
to make you well
psychological well-being is increased by
your going outside
so sit down everybody here's the
recommendation
go outside spend as much time outside
as you can go to the beach have a good
time at the beach
you know remind yourself what it is like
to live without
fear if you had had that kind of
recommendation
this would have been a very different
pandemic and instead we were having
officials close down beaches right close
close
limit you know you can't play tennis i
mean there's still signs up i think it's
it's allowed now but in portland i was
taking pictures and showing them on air
um all through last summer yes the
swimming pools were closed and i think
at that point we didn't fully know if
maybe water transmission was
possible so i did not come down strongly
against that it felt like a
a tragedy for the children but um but
okay
but you know sporting fields no baseball
no basketball no football no
tennis not even for kids yeah you know
kids who were immune by virtue of the
fact that kovid does not seem highly
capable
of infecting or damaging kids
they could have had sports and other
activities
outside they engaged with each other
engaged with each other there's
so much of the harm here was needless
and there's something about it
which one just has the impression that
there's a certain kind of authoritarian
that likes spoiling people's fun and
so instead of embracing the
counter-intuitive facts about covet and
saying you know what
covet is a disease of indoors it's the
buildings that are dangerous
if you can figure out how to stay out of
the buildings and
really think very hard about how not to
be in a car or
if it's winter and you know open the
windows all the way and turn the heat up
if it's winter
these sorts of pieces of advice about
how to continue to live a normal life
we would i think we'd in some ways be
like a different people at this point
because we would all discover what it
was like to be advised
actually you know the dangers in your
house but out there
you're safe and you know we might as
well i wouldn't say the dangers in your
house the danger is not in your house if
you you know if you aren't
letting lots of strangers come and come
and go the danger is about being
indoors among other people who might be
infected well
i i slightly disagree i mean i think
your your caution is accurate but
a lot of what was true here was that
once
kovid got loose in a house it tended to
bounce around to anybody who could catch
it absolutely and actually that you know
that
that mode of transmission is um appears
to be
if not the one of the most absolutely
most dangerous anxious to have somebody
bring cove at home
so which is like you know again another
of the recommendations uh
uh you know across the u.s anyway and i
don't know how widespread this was
outside the u.s was
if you get sick given that we're so
worried about icu beds what you do is
you go home
really you just guarantee it a lot more
people are going to get sick yeah
right exactly and so anyway i just
we will never know but i do wonder
if this might not have been an
enlightenment if instead of having
fingers wagged at us for smiling
outdoors
at each other without a mask on or
whatever it was right
if instead of being scolded for natural
the
sense of relief that you should have had
outdoors for those of us who did
experience it
right we also experienced stigma for
apparently not being decent
right that was preposterous that wasn't
science well i mean there was just
across pretty much every domain that
that sarsko v2
touched there were simple rubrics that
people
felt empowered to use against other
people to increase tribalism to increase
fear to make them their own cells feel
better and just you know here's here's
an anecdote which maybe i've mentioned
before but i was
walking outside without a mask at one
point a
big broad path and there was a woman
coming towards me with a mask
and she saw me and she saw someone way
behind me
um and gestured at her and yelled
in my general direction thank you for
wearing a mask
like you are yelling you are actually
spri
if you are sick the mask is not gonna
fully block when you're yelling and i'm
not speaking because i'm actually
interested in not getting you sick and
i'm six more than six feet away from you
and all of these things are true
and the idea that signaling to someone
you don't know
about how awful i am is making you feel
better
you know can't can't we all get a life
at some level like aren't we all capable
of bringing something to the world that
actually builds it
up don't we all have some ability to
create or to build
or to heal or to communicate or
to to adventure to discover to analyze
like these are all productive
amazing activities and i haven't begun
to
you know to exhaust all the possible
verbs
of productivity and and
and and building that humans can involve
themselves in and you know
is critique a important part of the
human endeavor it certainly is but
anyone whose job entirely is about
critique
is not really doing the world of service
yeah i mean i agree although um you know
i sort of think of critique as
the good version and criticism but i
but i this i i'm not sure that most
people will agree with me i'm not sure
that anyone would
really well but i actually thought about
this and i don't think that as much as
critique and criticism are
kind of flip sides with different
connotations and critique is the
positive and we know that critique is
absolutely necessary in science and in
art and
all endeavors if the only thing you
engage in is critique
i don't think you were doing the world
the kind of service that you imagine you
are
oh yeah definitely um
i guess i'm uh there's a sense
you know how there were teachers who had
a really deep insight into
human development and yes they were part
of the schools but
they also were sort of above that level
of
uh you know rules and regs right
they were flexible they had nuance they
were about discretion
and then there were other teachers who
were just all about the enforcement of
the rules to the letter
without any consideration of why the
rules necessarily existed
i feel like we are all somehow being
reduced to some
schoolyard that is being ruled by the
least imaginative
buzz-killing rule-loving authoritarian
nanny teachers and we just
gotta rebel right yeah the fact is there
are places where the rules are essential
and there are other places where
somebody made them up because they
wanted to tell you what to do
well there's i guess there's three
categories really there's places where
the rules are essential and they have to
be the right rules
and then there are places where the
rules aren't essential but if you're
going to have rules they have to be the
right rules
and then there are places where you
don't need rules and if there are rules
at all you should be free to ignore them
right but in this case right
it is amazing to me that in some sense
the solution to a huge
number of the problems created by kovitt
problems that none of us invited
right a huge number of those problems
were solved
by going outside i mean even the social
distance that this put between us
didn't need to be maintained in the same
way outside that's right right and
you know if you know we have this saying
uh in the pacific northwest
there's no such thing as bad weather
just inappropriate clothing
you know if you have to discover what
you're gonna have to do in order to be
outside in the winter because
there's a new wrinkle that makes it hard
to be inside right okay
that's the thing we should have advised
people here's you know here's the
the gentle slope to getting yourself
active in cold weather in your
environment or something like that
and you know i just i i i feel terrible
for our species
that we allowed this to happen to us and
not just
you know the disease but the way we
botched
the coping mechanism we just screwed it
up well
i love this framing of yours you know
the idea that instead of this
just debilitating debacle worldwide
debacle that we find ourselves in now
it actually could have been the
opportunity for another enlightenment
yeah how tragic yeah utterly tragic
utterly tragic and
it's tragic but you know what there's a
reason we focus on tragedy and that's
because
you can learn from it and that's right
you know we don't know what the next
thing that has the magnitude of covid
could be it's hard to imagine such a
thing but you know what
given the way disasters are going the
magnitude is going up
something is going to be down the pike
let's not screw it up next time
[Music]